I just started playing the game when it
came to my nose I'd never felt anything
so strong before the farts thinks so
real
[Music]
best immersive experience ever in South
Park the fracture butthole you are
playing the new kid in town in a hero
and one of your special abilities is
really power of your ass the only way to
really help people experience that
strength is to really make sure that
they can feel it and that means getting
really close this time we wanted to come
up with the most authentic most
immersive way for players to be able to
experience the power of Manoogian shin
Saku Saku the flock shall depart to
wholeness a second cocky what about any
walk in a category monster so called a
warrior et moi
oh hi Ida yomo yomo Soumitra she kuraha
mark to you take a memo to me show give
me a third monster
Suzuno Secaucus on a rocket external
cadet
notice lift it was exactly as if someone
had parted right in my face I was like
holy [__]
this is a real fart holiday to know you
know not an annoying external body or
solution can you can go
Fukakusa Munich at audacity kyoko
english master Scott Samana ticklish our
white man an acid super notes
pathos and we can talk t zu enough Tim
can switch on the Honda be soft you are
Alice under Juarez and far as concerti
Mad Hatter anger averted and the
perverts Ukrainian help me as thousand
Foods in the home the force may English
gay London weird he might even thoughts
constantly have such day
Oh Joseph it's fun climbing
[Music]